no context i could provide here would
make this any less weird it is what it
is and it stands on its own terms ready
here we go
question
mr president you said if you see someone
getting ready to throw a tomato just
knock the crop out of them would you
that was your statement answer trump oh
yeah it was very dangerous
question what was very dangerous answer
trump we were threatened question with
what
answer trump they were going to throw
fruit it's worse than tomato it's other
things also but tomato when they start
doing that stuff it's very dangerous
that's actually literally the transcript
it's very dangerous stuff you can get
killed with those things absolutely
terrified of bananas
what in the [ __ ] is going on what is
going on
bananas
pineapples tomatoes
killer killer fruit and vegetables
oh man for a guy who's never seen a
fruit or vegetable on his plate it
really is it re
really is alarming that he thinks fruits
and vegetables are dangerous
they're dangerous
flying around
oh my god
this is real
it's it's [ __ ] real and he didn't
just like say this like in some dumb ass
interview some
[ __ ] [ __ ] from some trader tv news
network type thing
no he said this under oath
in a deposition
literally he swore an oath to tell the
truth nothing but the truth so help him
trump
this [ __ ]
is terrified of hecklers
throwing dangerous fruit at him
can you imagine
can you imagine
if if they were to toss
a banana at my face
and then i'd have to wipe it off and all
my makeup
and all the [ __ ] i take off my face
comes off with that banana
oh my god he's scared of nanners folks
he's scared of the nanners
oh [ __ ] i'm not kidding you if you're
just hearing this donald trump
said in a [ __ ] deposition under oath
this is not again this is not some dumb
[ __ ] interview
this is not just [ __ ] steve bannon or
fox news or
whatever the [ __ ] trader tv network that
you're that you're out there [ __ ]
having the cheeto dust mobster on where
he's talking about how people are
throwing
[ __ ] at him you know you'll remember the
cans of soup thing i made a joke about
it this morning when he was talking
about cans of soup and people antifa
throwing cans of soup and [ __ ]
you remember that
back when he was president
it wasn't like that he was under oath
and he's talking about how
fruits and vegetables
are dangerous if they're thrown at him
and he's he's scary he's he's he's
really frightened that hecklers would
throw dangerous
dangerous nanners in him
oh my god can you imagine if a mater hit
me oh [ __ ] that would be
it'd be deadly
i don't know maybe he thinks maybe he
thinks fruits and vegetables are [ __ ]
deadly maybe that's why he only eats big
macs and buckets of kfc
it could be i don't know i don't know
there's a lot of [ __ ] that this guy
seems to believe that is absolutely
[ __ ] bonkers batshit crazy
whoosh
whoosh
under oath
he said
that
someone chucking
a banana at him is dangerous
now do you remember
the end of
george w bush's
10 years president it was a second term
coming to the end i forget he was in a
foreign country we might pull up the
video here in a minute
and a guy takes off his shoe
takes off his shoe and tosses it at that
[ __ ] you remember that it was
actually kind of weird because like
that just just
doesn't happen with the secret service
standing there and it took a little bit
to you know get the guy and for secret
service come in me remember that right
and the guy threw the shoe at at george
w bush when he was the president of the
united states
and even the coward that george w bush
might be he at least ducked and he still
stood there he was like oh there's got
to be another shoe this motherfucker's
got two shoes i mean you know he
expected another shoe right
like he thought uh well there's one
where's the second one
right
but donald trump is terrified
terrified of a bunch of bananas
whoo
as if we don't have better [ __ ]
[ __ ] worry about but that's hilarious
that is [ __ ] hilarious that this is
their macho machismo this this is the
guy they look to to be a tough manly man
tucker carlson tens his balls to look
like donald trump's face
so that he can be manly like donald
trump
you gotta have the trump face tan balls
to be a manly man
and here he is terrified of maters
whoosh